now we're in a post lockdown world the
future of work and whether we stay
distributed or go back to the office
isn't a big sort of state of flux and I
know lots of people are making
predictions that we should all stay away
or we should all come to work or we
should be some sort of hybrid and the
answer is it's still kind of a mess and
some companies are experimenting with
anything and in between and we ourselves
as uh as employees are also
experimenting with what works for us I
will tell you one thing though the
promise or the ideal of staying away
from work and being a completely
um uh remote employee is starting to
show it's starting to backfire a little
bit we're starting to show people
feeling disconnected
um uh we're starting to see declines in
brainstorming and creative ideas but
also relationships at work are starting
to struggle as a result so I think
whether we like it or not we're going to
have to start coming back to work in
some way shape or form at least in some
hybrid fashion I think the future of
completely remote work except for rare
circumstances is probably not going to
be the norm
so every time there's been new
technology uh we have adapted and
changed of course I remember this is
going to date me now but I used to have
like a mind like a steel trap for phone
numbers I knew everybody's phone numbers
I knew 10 50 100 phone numbers like
family friends I just knew old phone
numbers and then for my birthday I got a
Casio digital diary with 2K of memory
and I was able to put all my phone
numbers in there now I I know my phone
number and I know my sister's phone
number and that's it I don't even know
my best friend's phone number I just
type in their names in my phone my mind
literally doesn't work that way anymore
because the technology is did the work
for me and my brain said fine screw you
you got the technology you don't need me
so yes of course there are going to be
adaptations you know the Iliad for
example was a was a a a book that we
read in high school or college that's
this big that was handed down by
storytelling over Generations until we
figured out the printing press and now
we can't remember stories that long we
just can't do it so will our minds
adjust thanks to Ai and chat GPT of
course for better and For Worse yes we
will adapt
I love the idea of a four day work week
um uh and I think that you know for
anybody who's ever sort of taken a day
off you don't actually get a day off
what you have is five days of work to do
in four days and for anybody who's ever
taken a vacation you know that that time
before the vacation you're more
productive than you've ever been because
you hope not to do any work while you're
on vacation so as long as we hold each
other to standards where we're not doing
four days of work but rather we're doing
five days of work and four days meaning
there's less time for long lunches
there's less time for long breaks and as
long as we can get all the work done in
four days yeah I'm a fan so I know I've
thought about experimenting with it
myself
um uh I I know that there's a lot of
studies being done on it but I'm totally
Curious by it and I'm definitely curious
and I like the idea of experimenting and
I think I think companies should
announce pilot programs if they're
curious as opposed to you know making
big decisions you don't have to you
don't have to sort of go go Whole Hog
you can you can experiment but yeah I I
find it really curious no it's not
because that the amount of money you
need to make to survive is actually not
a very high number
um you know you're paying for lifestyle
you're paying for desire paying for
disposable income you're paying to give
away money you're paying for Freedom
um uh but simply if if your only
motivation is to make enough money to
survive I mean 30 bucks a day will cover
that you know but if you want to live
somewhere you know
um you probably want to make more money
so no why money is a result
um money is not a purpose a purpose is
something that's potentially
unachievable and unrealizable and it's
um something that's inspiring you know
if you talk to somebody and say so why
do you do what you do like well I just
make money to survive like you're not
inspiring anybody I hate to break it to
you the thing that keeps me going in the
darkest of times quite frankly are my
friends and I don't mean me like I'm
doing this for my friends I mean
literally calling up my friends and
saying I'm struggling and my friends are
there for me
um uh yes my why is always there uh yes
my vision is always there but dark times
for me for me are not the lack of
optimism and the lack of inspiration for
cause it's the lack of energy to do it
um for me dark times is not loss of
vision it's loss of energy and it's loss
of desire to get out of bed and do it
and and when I realize that I'm not
alone and I'm surrounded by people who
love me and care about me
um that's that's the reason I get out of
bed is I want to make them proud and I
want to do right by them and it's kind
of a magical thing when you do something
out of gratitude
um when you believe in the mission you
have a toxic bus there's first of all a
are they truly toxic are they just a bad
leader there is a difference
um a bad leader is somebody who doesn't
know what they're doing they're
operating a fear they have a ton of
pressure on them they don't have the
skills and we can actually operate with
empathy for them you know which is you
know to go to your boss and say hey look
I'm here I believe what you believe and
I'm here to help you succeed and make
you look great so you know we can work
together or hey today was really
difficult you came down really hard on
us are you okay that's what operating
with empathy is if you truly have a
toxic boss
um but you love the mission of the
organization if the organization is big
enough a are there opportunities uh
somewhere else in the organization that
you can you can look to
um have you sought advice from other
people in the organization I want to
stay here I love it here but I'm really
struggling with my boss and
unfortunately worst case scenario
sometimes you have to leave now toxicity
again is something very different than
somebody who's a bad leader
um bad leaders make our lives difficult
but we can also learn a lot from them
about how not to do things and we can
actually learn to become the leader we
wish we had and actually take care of
them as well but if it's truly truly
truly toxic look for other places inside
the organization or I hate to say it you
may have to leave
the number one rule about leaving a job
is you always want to go to something
not away from something right if you're
just going to take whatever the next
thing is it sounds like you're trying to
get away from something that's a bad
motivation to take another job because
you may not end up in something better
um you always want to go to something
um and I'd rather you hold out a little
bit and wait for something that actually
inspires you or more important to go
work for a person who inspires you that
you really want to work for that's
actually more important than the job or
the money is the person you're going to
work for every job decision I've ever
made my entire career I chose who I was
going to work for not what account or
even how much they were going to pay pay
me because I wanted to grow and I'm
going to grow more with somebody who
takes care of me and I'd rather you wait
out a little bit because if you're going
to take something that's dissatisfying
you just want to get away from it you'll
end up in something dissatisfying again
and you're going to just repeat the
process so I would hang out a little
longer if you can to find a person you
really want to work for
ha it's a great question I think we very
often confuse mentor and Champion right
A Champion is somebody in your company
usually in your in your hierarchy
usually who can influence your career
put in a good phone call for you you
know encourage other people to take a
take a bet on you
that's a champion a mentor is somebody
who just cares that you're growing cares
that you're doing well and probably has
no ability to impact your career they're
outside of your your hierarchy and maybe
outside of your company or outside your
industry they just care about you
um so I've always found it weird when we
assign mentors because yes I think a
true Mentor is kind of like a true
friend which is they always have time
for you and they really do care about
you
um so yeah I do believe that uh that a
mentor should care about you and a true
mentorship program is kind of like
making a friend program and if it
doesn't connect you should find another
one
um yeah mentors are they should they
should care about you yes
so whenever I get really nervous
um and anxious before a big talk
um there are two things that I remind
myself number one it goes back to a
lesson I learned a couple years ago when
I was watching the Olympics and all of
the journalists asked all of the
um athletes are you nervous or were you
nervous and all of the athletes gave the
same answer no I'm excited no I was
excited
and if you think about it what are the
characteristics of nervousness your
heart starts pounding your hands get
clammy you start envisioning the future
well what are the characteristics of
excitement your heart starts pounding
your hands get clamped you start
envisioning the future
the reason that the journalists were
asking are you nervous is because they
would be nervous
but these Elite athletes had learned to
interpret that data as excitement that's
why they're Elite athletes
and so I did a little experiment I was
on a plane and we hit some really bad
turbulence and I got really nervous and
I said out loud to myself this is
exciting
and in an instant I felt fine my body
instantly was able to convert all of
that data that says you're nervous to
this is exciting and I use that when I
go out on stage as well if I get nervous
I say to myself this is exciting and I
remind myself instead of being like Oh
my God I can't believe I'm not qualified
to be here the people here are more
important than me they're more
successful than me when as soon as I
convert to excitement then I say to
myself oh my God I can't believe I get
to share the stage with these people I
can't believe that I'm one of them my
goodness this is incredible and it
happens instantaneously it's kind of
incredible so the next time you get
anxious just tell yourself this is
exciting oh and the second thing because
I said there were two things the second
thing I always remind myself I'm here to
give so when I get really anxious I
remember that somebody asked me to come
out here and talk to somebody with I
don't care if they like me I don't care
if they follow me on social I just
remind myself I have a point of view and
a perspective and I'm here to give
that's all and those two things help me
combat anxiety anxiety and nervousness
every time